hello my name is asaki petrossian i am a
senior postdoc in the golf r lab at
children's hospital los angeles in the
division of urology today i'll be
discussing the mechanism of protocol
damage and alpers syndrome insights from
output on a chip
i have no conflict of interest to
disclose
i'll start off with a brief background
about the kidney the kidney has many
functions one of its main function is to
filter our blood the functional unit of
the kidney the post and the middle
portion of the drawing is the nephron
blood filtration occurs in the
glomerulus of the nephron highlighted in
the red square box and as shown in this
sem image that you could appreciate the
complexities of this particular
structure
now one important thing to note is that
no new nephrons can be generated in
adult life we are born with a set number
of nephrons that could range from half a
million to a million per person
the key component that allows proper
blood filtration to occur is the
glomerular basement membrane that is
generated by the interaction between
highly specialized glomerular cells such
as the protocytes as shown above and
the endothelial cells they deposit this
particular
basement membrane
now this deposition is uh
created through the interaction of
protocytes and endothelial cells
uh the gbm is has extracellular matrix
components laminin five to one and
collagen four and agaron
early in development the nascent's gbm
actually is composed of collagen 4 fo1
and 2 trimers however the adult mature
glomeruli should switch this
to
express collagen for alpha 3 4 and 5.
this switch is a key
to allowing proper glomerular filtration
to occur in adult life
as you could see the system is highly
complex
and it is quite difficult to generate
the system in a 2d system spheroids or
transworld cultures of protozoa and
human glomerular endothelial cells and
to replicate this filtration barrier
in patients with l precision
unfortunately there is a mutation in
collagen for alpha 3 or 4 or 5 trimer
this particular mutation it does not
allow the the mature formation of the
gpm the switch from collagen for fo1 to
trimer to cauldron iv alpha 3 4 and 5.
as you could see in this tm image in the
normal gbm versus the output gpm there's
abnormal splits and laminated gbm
uh most of the patients carry the
mutation for cauldron 4 alpha 5 which is
an x-linked mutation that accounts for
85 of the cases there's also the
autosomal forms of collagen for alpha-3
or cauldron for alpha-4 uh which is
predominantly uh
from a recessive form or could occur
from an autosomal dominant form
patients with alport syndrome actually
have many clinical manifestations
one of the main ones is that they have
gbm structural defects this uh causes
the infiltration of immune cells the
increased opposition of extracellular
matrix glomerular scarring obstruction
of the glomerular capillaries reduced
renal blood flow and protein in eurea
causing progressive kidney failure
patients also suffer from hearing loss
and eyesight problems
now
it is key
to develop a model to study this
particular system however the
development of kidney glimmer specific
model is challenged by the lack of human
physiological relevant models
uh recently um
the human on a chip system has been
quite interesting using microfluid and
organ ownership platform to study uh
various organs and in connection with
one another
uh of interest is also the tubules on
the chip and the kidney on the chip to
really begin to understand how to target
specific organ types with specific types
of treatments
so how do we replicate a better
glomerular filtration architecture that
is devoid of barriers between
endothelial uh and protocytes to allow
them to create this
complex glomeral basement membrane for
us to study so we have worked with
mometis and we have used their
three-lane organa organo plate
um
basically this particular system uses a
face guide this allows the control of
channel filling takes advantage of
surface tension and formation of a
miscus by collagen
you could see over here
we have the upper lane in a
b is the middle lane and c
is the lower lane
so the way we generate the glomerulus on
a chip using this system
to create a filtration barrier is by
using the middle lane e
and uh filling this with collagen
and then in c we initially seed
protocytes
and allow them to
align
and then we wait 24 hours and seed
endothelial cells allow them to in line
and then we place them on a shaker and
allow fluid flow in channel c the
filtrate would be collected and channel
f and as you could see there is no
barrier between the protocytes and
endothelial cells so this allows them to
interact with one another and create
this complex glamorous basement membrane
there are multiple sources we take
prototypes from
protocytes uh we isolate either from
directly from the kidney of human
patients or we also use our amniotic
fluid system where we isolate amniotic
fluid uh kidney progenitor cells
and then we differentiate this
progenitor cells into protocytes
from and we could take amniotic fluid
from healthy patients and also output
patients and isolate protocites from
this system for glomerulonedotil cells
which are highly specialized we directly
take them from the kidney
um human kidney so the way we take
glumery endothelial cells is by
initially
taking human kidneys digesting them and
isolating the glomeruli shown in b
and then once we isolate the glomera and
purify them we digest them further and
we sort them for marker cd31
see the third one is specific for
endothelial cells and once these cells
have been isolated we expand them
and we test them to make sure that they
are indeed endothelial cells we see that
they lack the expression of photosite
marker w21 and also nephron
however they are positive for cd31 shown
below
we also know that they are specifically
expressing markers that are specific for
glomeral endothelial cells such as edh3
we see an a the expression of egh3 in
our cultured glomeral endothelial cells
we also see the staining they stain
positive for eagh3
and we know adhd is highly specific for
glomerular endothelial cells
these cells also in culture are able to
create this complex fenestration that
are important for glomerular endothelial
cell function
we also see the presence of glycocolyx
components such as in the can 1 4 and
hypersulfate that we showed through flow
analysis to show their expression along
with staining
now human protocytes are derived from
amniotic fluid cells the way we
do this is by initially expanding the
amniotic fluid cells in chain media
and then using three markers a cd24 ob
coherent and put a collection and
isolating these cells uh through flow
analysis and flow cytometry we say that
around point eight to one point six
percent of the total amniotic fluid
expanded cells are indeed positive for
these three markers we take these cells
we expand them in shank and then when
we're ready we differentiate a portion
using red median collagen type 1 coating
after differentiation for uh two weeks
we see that they present the parasite
morphological characteristics where we
see foot processes
we've also
extracted protein from the cells
cultured in vitro and we do see that
they do indeed
deposit
gbm components such as collagen for
alpha 3 4 and 5 along with lamin and
alpha 5
that are specifically uh deposit
deposited by
protocytes
we also see the expression
of protozoa specific markers to
immunofluorescence uh
amino fluorescence uh and we see the
expression of nephrine and protocin
we've also done flow analysis on these
cells to make sure that they are indeed
protocytes using protozoa specific
markers such as wt1 and nephrine and we
do indeed see that they are positive for
both but they lack expression of
endothelial markers cd31
we could also using the same system
isolate outport protocytes as well
with the generous donation of output
patients of their amniotic fluid we were
able to isolate upward
porocites as well
in this example this particular patient
had a mutation in collagen for alpha 5
chain
and
we've taken the amniotic fluid we've
expanded the cells in shank and then
we've isolated
upward um kidney progenitor cells using
the three markers
cd24 ob could hear coherent and put a
collection
we proceeded to differentiating these
cells and we see through western blot uh
the human uh
total uh kidney do indeed have
expression of collagen for alpha 3 uh
collagen for
alpha 3 trimers and collagen for alpha 5
expression
however and and also the
kidney progenitor cells that have been
differentiated that are not outpoured do
also express the collagen for
alpha 3 and 5.
however output
protocytes
lack the expression of this collagen for
alpha 3 which is a characteristics of
the mutation
we've also done rna sequencing analysis
of output protocytes and
protocites that are not outpoured
and we see that indeed an output of
protocytes there is a higher expression
of genes involved in glomerular basement
membrane deposition
and matrix cell bond
along with vgf signaling and activation
of
iii kinase
pathways and we see a down regulation of
specific markers such as wt1 uh lymphex1
and sulf1
so now that we have our cells uh we
proceeded to
placing them on the chip so the way we
do this is we take the three lane system
we initially see collagen and channel e
and then we proceed to seeding the
procedes
and after 24 hours seeing the
glomerular endothelial cells
and as i said there is no membrane
between them
and then we allow them to interact and
after three days
to a week we see that
they align
nicely they are separated
and then they begin to deposit important
components of the glomerular basement
membrane such as collagen four alpha
four
collagen four for one and two and
laminin alpha five
we see the interaction of podocytes and
endothelial cells and the presence of
the collagen for alpha three
so we've also isolated uh these cells
and we've done analysis and we do indeed
see expression of collagen for alpha 3
as well
with western blot and
lamin and alpha 5. so we see that indeed
once we see the cells um
they are able to produce the components
of the glomerular basement membrane so
there's collagen for alpha 3 4 and 5
trimers and laminin
and we've confirmed this with healthy
prototypes as well that are not uh that
are directly isolated from the kidney
so now that we have the
system in place can we create the output
glomerus on a chip
so to model the outpour syndrome we
obtained amniotic fluid from different
uh fetuses carrying the collagen for
alpha 4 or collagen for alpha 5 mutation
and we've derived amniotic fluid output
progenitor cells
we currently have five different lines
and our lines are generously donated by
patients and our devoid of manipulations
thus they carry the natural mutation
we've taken the cells and we've uh
expanded them the amniotic fluid
and we've isolated using the three
markers as shown
here first uh
to the to isolate the prostate
progenitors
uh which is cd24 pre-klexinopicarin
and we've received around 1.7 percent
and we've also see that these cells on
the chip
and using the output of photosites we
generated the chips and we showed that
there is indeed an alteration in the
production of cauldron 4 alpha 3.
through western blotting and staining we
see that collagen for alpha 4 and
chips that are made from
protocytes that are not outpoured do
indeed deposit collagen for alpha 4
however in output chips we see the
absence of this we also showed this
through western blotting
that indeed uh
in the human kidney we see the presence
of this uh
have and also in the chips that are
in cells that are not outpoured however
in the upper chip this particular
expression is missing
so since we've created the chips and
they seem to mimic what is occurring in
vivo in patients what about their
filtration could we do a functional
assessment on them
so we've added uh 50 conjugated bsa
in the physiological concentration of 40
milligrams per ml
in the chips that we've designed using
output protocytes uh output parasites
and also prototypes that do not have uh
outport
and we see that after five minutes uh
the chips are not leaking but after 60
minutes the output protocytes begin to
leak
and there is a significant leakage of
albumin in the output protocytes
compared to uh prosites that are not
outpoured
so there seems to be a glomerular
basement membrane defect which is a
culprit of outport
and
so we mimic this but what about other
signaling pathways that are affected
during disease progression could we also
see this using this chip system
so we were interested in mir 193 and
understanding its role in regulating
glomerular homeostasis
what we've done is we've done bulk rna
sequencing of alpert protocytes versus
healthy protocytes and we see an
upregulation of mir-193a
now upregulation of mir-193a induces
foot process affectment and development
of focal segmental glomerulosclerosis
and animal models
the downstream targets of 193a are wt1
and osteopotene
so what happens in alport
uh in vivo what we've seen is that
indeed in mice uh that have the mutation
for collagen 4 alpha 5
do indeed have an up regulation of mere
193a in their glomeruli
and we've also seen that they also have
alteration of wt1 and osteopotene which
are the downstream targets of mir 193a
what about our cells
looking at the alkart uh protocytes
versus healthy protocytes we do and see
that
indeed see that mir183a is upregulated
in the output protocytes however one
important note is that we could actually
target this using antiglomeres so we
show that
inhibition of mir193a
using antigo mirrors uh for mere 183a
actually
reverses this over expression
so uh mimicking the output phenotype and
the glomerulus on the chip
does the same mechanism that we see in
the evil and vitro applied to the chip
so what we did is we created chips using
output protocytes and also healthy
protocytes
and then we
[Music]
isolated the protocytes and endothelial
cells and we've done
qpcr on them
and we do indeed see
aside from the up regulation of mir 193
a
uh we see
alteration of its downstream targets
such as osteoporotin bgf and wt1 in the
outport versus the healthy protocytes
one important note is that glomerulon
digital cells do not express mere 183a
so we see the same trend
that we saw before what about the
filtrate since we have this perfect
system to also collect the filtrate
so what we've done is we've performed
proteomics on the l-port glomerulone
chip filtrate
we've collected the filtrate and we've
identified hume 80 human highly
expressed proteins we do use fbs in our
media so we've excluded the 280 bovine
highly expressed proteins from the media
but from all from the 80 human highly
expressed proteins that we've identified
in the filtrate we've only found 17 that
were
in the output filtrate these were
serpent c1 uh thrombospondin fibronectin
now mirrors can regulate serpents and
glomerular dysfunction and alport
syndrome correlates with the
dysregulation of serpents
so we wanted to check if we target mere
193 a would this directly or affect the
serpent uh expression as well
so what we've done is we've given antigo
mirrors uh to the
alport glomerus on a chip
and what we see that
uh here
in normal glomerulus on the chip we see
a certain level of expression of serpent
a3 however in the output glamorous on
the trip serpent a3 is highly expressed
but once we target mere 1 and b3a we
could actually restore the serpent a3
expression to normal so the glomerus on
a chip
of alport is an excellent system to
validate our
mouse data to study
output disease and also identify
mechanisms and biomarkers we could
directly target to help outport patients
we've also validated our data
using digital spatial transcriptomic
profiling
of alport biopsies
and we've analyzed
we've
taken a healthy
healthy patient glomerulus
and an alport patient
glomerulus
and we've analyzed them
and we do indeed see that their
principle component analysis they are
quite different
uh but
we also confirm that there is a
differential expression of
thrombospondin
xeroplasmin plasminogen and citronectin
uh in the output patient as we found
within our filtrate also in our rna
sequencing data
the analysis still is ongoing
however from this uh we could conclude
that we've successfully created a
barrier-free system
that allows human protocytes and uh
glomerular endothelial cells to interact
with one another creating the glomerular
basement membrane
and we found that they are able to
correctly deposit uh the glomerular
basement membrane depending on their
phenotype while the output protocols
fail to create
the collagen for alpha three four and
five trimer the normal chlorosides are
capable of doing this and they're also
capable of preventing leakage of
proteins such as albumin
the chips could be specific
patient-specific
and um
we could see that in outport patients uh
the chips do leak we've also identified
a
mere 193a as a potential target
uh to treat alpert disease
and uh the system is versatile so we
could do disease moleculeing we took it
to biomarkers and we could further
vertify this data in animal studies and
also using digital spatial
transcriptomics
so with that i would like to thank my
lab uh our division chief doctor roger
de felipe dr perrin mypi and dr desako
who also copy eyed on this project um
and also all our collaborators
and the funding that made this
possible specifically the gulf war
kidney funding by
michael and elisa shankman
thank you